just just cheese sticks
oh cheek yeah i can guarantee though
that these are probably not the best
tasting cheese well i also grew up with
these but uh after about
age eight i stopped eating them because
i had proper cheese in australia
when you have real cheese you can't eat
this but if you if you're american
i'm not [ __ ] this is not just cheese
this is cheese with kama boko which is
fish cake
you should have said that you should let
him try it just give it a go you want to
try it girl
sure you're on the show there's you
can't say no
i'm going to be honest this is probably
the least appetizing
looking thing that we've had on today oh
dude you kind of just rip it open like
that we've had some pretty gross [ __ ]
but this looks vile
this actually looks disgusting this
looks like on the same level with
squishy what's the ratio of cheese to
like fish
you don't want to smell them
how do i open this this immediately just
like grab the top and just put
that like a banana
[Music]
these boys are struggling here here i'll
open them up for you there you go okay
let me let me let me get the [ __ ] okay
yeah there you go just get a knife
there we go oh okay hell yo
fort knox should be this actually taste
this actually smells
close to vomit i think as close to
vomiting it's like a cheesy vomit isn't
it
yeah that's it all right i'm gonna have
one because i haven't i haven't had
these
i haven't had one of these since i was
about eight okay
is this gonna be cheese flavored vomit
like i imagined it to be
yeah it tastes exactly how i remember it
oh we want to try this japanese snack
for the first time
honestly it doesn't taste as bad as i
thought it would it
oh no it tastes it tastes like you're
eating
plastic yeah it tastes like you're
eating plastic and then you get the
fish aftertaste the fish where is the
cheese in there
i don't taste anything that was not
cheese that was plastic you can't you
can't
that's a plastic fish sausage that's
fish that's fish flavored plastic